Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 ahsoka tano
video i'll explain what was happening with her
after order 66 what they've said about her on
the show what her future is on the mandalorian
series and in the star wars live-action disney
plus series if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes we'll do a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
post all your predictions for ahsoka tano on the
video careful for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far if you haven't seen
any of the episodes but first things first friday
the title of the mandalorian season 2 episode
5 has been reported as the jedi which is just
a general reference to ahsoka tano and the enemy
sorcerers the mandalorian and the armor spoke of
in the season 2 trailer the jedi that mando is
quested to take baby yoda to also it broadly
references to the show invoking the lore of
the jedi to the series in a much bigger way
like the concept of jedi and the force are coming
to the mandalorian series in a much bigger way
than before there's still a ton of questions that
the show has raised during season 1 and season 2
so far about where for sensitive characters and
former jedi that survived order 66 fit into the
show going forward like how many jedi are we going
to see over the next couple of seasons most of
those answers will come with episode 5 or they'll
at least give us enough information to provide
some context for that as at the end of episode
four he's currently returned to his original
mission with the directions given to him by bo
katan and the other mandalorians he's going to
the city of calidan on the forest planet of corvus
there were a lot of you that asked if kaladan was
meant to be a dune reference to kaladan the former
seat of house of tradies before the events of
the first novel or the movie depending on what
you're talking about the way it appears in the
official subtitles of the show though it's spelled
differently so i assumed at the time in episode
three when bogatan said that it wasn't meant to be
a direct reference to dune but it does sound very
similar corvus though is a star wars name it's
the name of the ship that iden versio's inferno
squad uses during battlefront that character is
still alive during this period in the timeline
so because katie sackoff went from doing the
animated version of her character Bo Katan
on the clone wars and rebels to doing the live
action version it's always possible that janina
gavin carr could do the same thing with iden
versio i know everyone's asking for cal kestis
to show up on the series now from the jedi fallen
order game janina gavankar actually already got a
secret mark hamill style cameo during episode 3
though if you can believe it she played the mon
calamari dog master here who repaired the razor
crest so we'll see if she eventually shows up in
a bigger way in future seasons as for iden versio
character pretty much anybody from anywhere in the
canon in legends is totally fair game if they're
bringing stuff from the dark forces video game
like the dark troopers back into main canon they
could do that for anything that they want even
mark hamill had a cameo during season 1 as the
ev99 droid bartender in the most iceland cantina
you wouldn't have known it was him unless they
told you because they changed his voice so much
so pretty much anything is possible but the
mandalorian is finally going to ahsoka tano
they've been hyping her up all year long a lot of
you had questions about how she's going to change
the show so fundamentally because she's such a
huge character she's one of the most powerful
force users or former jedi left in the galaxy
after order 66 and reportedly rosario dawson
who's going to be playing her signed a pretty big
contract with the star wars disney people that
cover a bunch of future appearances and potential
spin-off series for ahsoka so theoretically
there's going to be a lot of live-action ahsoka in
the next couple of years in a bunch of different
places but probably the most important thing
in all this though is the idea that baby yoda
will probably never leave the mandalorian series
and the mandalorian will always be the main
star wars disney plus series during this part of
the timeline right after return of the jedi but
before the events of the new star wars movies
like force awakens or ryza skywalker mando
effectively dominates this stretch of history
from a production standpoint with this giant new
galactic civil war in the battle for the planet
mandalore that they've been hyping up there will
be multiple spin-offs but this series will always
be the main one until they decide to end the show
in however many years season 5 season 7 whatever
the way ahsoka is being pitched on the mandalorian
series is a little like Bo Katan really important
characters fan favorites that show up play a
really important role in the mando and baby yoda's
character development in the overall narrative of
the galaxy but then they cycle out with mando
going on to encounter other big characters from
the star wars universe as he continues on his
journey so at the moment they're really more like
important side characters not main characters so
logically there will have to be some reason that
baby yoda can't stay with ahsoka permanently mando
is taking him to her with the intent to leave him
and then return to his regular life as a bounty
hunter and trying to track down the remnants of
his former clan including the armor she's still
alive out there somewhere then there's also the
recent revelation that bogatan gave him dropping
all that knowledge about the way and what that
really means in the larger context like he grew
up being taught completely different things and
values about the mandalorians than what bokotan
just told him so he's still kind of in shock
about that and she's trying to recruit him as a
night owl to join their war against maf gideon and
retake the planet mandalore in the darksaber so
for those of you asking why ahsoka wouldn't take
baby yoda from him even if he tries to take off
i think there's a couple answers to that question
first there's the immediate threat of moff gideon
and the dark troopers from the end of episode four
that tag scene where he asks if mando still has
the asset talking about the child and then says
we will be ready for them with his evil smile
giancarlo esposito is so good at doing that evil
guy smile we're in the back half of the season so
the plot is starting to pick up the pace getting
crazier and crazier moff gideon will probably
show up really soon with the dark troopers
and try to take baby oda by force make as many
jedi preferences as you want in that situation
mando would probably feel obligated to try and
protect the child so he'd stick around for that
to say nothing of boba fett showing up to
complicate things as well he's sort of an x factor
this season we haven't seen him since the end of
episode 1 but we know that he's clocking mando he
wants his armor back and he's a bounty hunter by
trade moff gideon still has that very large bounty
out on the child so do the easy math on that boba
fett will probably show up sometime soon again too
and there's the idea that ahsoka herself will
recognize the father-son relationship that mando
has with baby yoda and how much they need each
other and she'll decide that it's best that they
stay together for both their sakes long term
remember grief cargo's speech at the end of
season 1 episode 8 he made this joke about mando
protecting baby yoda and just maybe baby yoda
would protect mando the armor also referenced
that when they were talking about his crest for
the mudhorn that she was making him in the finale
from an overall narrative standpoint that's the
main reason the show will always be about the
two of them like the title of the show the
mandalorian doesn't just refer to din jarn it also
refers to baby yoda because they're a clan of two
as decreed by the armor that being said though
ahsoka brings the wisdom of the jedi to the show
in a way we haven't seen yet mando still thinks
of the jedi as enemy sorcerers he knows nothing
of the force even though he quoted the trademark
phrase may the force be with you ahsoka can just
clarify a lot of his misconceptions about the
jedi and give him some guidance and help teach
a few things to baby yoda he's already so powerful
and so connected to the force that most of what he
does his abilities are all instinctual just him
reacting in the moment without thinking about it
and if you listen to a lot of the interviews
before season 2 started giancarlo esposito
says that on the show the way that they write the
child baby yoda is that he has no ego he's neither
good nor evil he's just full of infinite
potential and it's through his experiences
and interactions with other characters like mando
and moff gideon that he learns to be good or evil
but talking more about ahsoka's history charting
the timeline of the jedi and the force users after
order 66 the main reason why we're just learning
about ahsoka now on the show is because after
order 66 which they covered in the clone wars
season 7 final episodes they're fantastic if you
never watch those i did a couple videos for those
ahsoka buries her comrades then left behind her
last remaining lightsaber that anakin skywalker
had given to her in order to make the empire think
that she had died too going into hiding like all
the other jedi that survived the purge like a lot
of you've been wondering if calcus will ever show
up on the mandalorian series he goes into hiding
effectively trying to keep it on the dl after
order 66. but right after this happens she heads
to the other side of the outer rim territories
away from the main hyperspace routes to try and
stay as off the radar as possible on a planet
called thibasca there is a book that covers a
lot of this part of her history and as you would
expect even though she is trying to keep as quiet
as possible she winds up getting involved in local
affairs helping people around her which causes her
to have run-ins with more stormtroopers so she
continues to have to jump around from planet
to planet in the outer rim never staying in
any one place for too long but eventually she
winds up defeating a sith inquisitor taking his
lightsaber crystals purifying them using them to
create her two new dual white lightsabers that
you see her fighting with in star wars rebels
so these are different lightsabers than the ones
that anakin made for her during the clone wars
eventually bail organa learned that she was still
alive in the outer rim and recruited her into
the rebellion formally before the events of new
hope they brought her onto the star wars rebels
tv series and she goes by the code name fulcrum
just helping the rebels out then just prior to
the events of a new hope she finally meets anakin
skywalker again after he became darth vader and
they have a big reunion battle in the sith temple
they'd had visions of each other up to this point
but this is the first time that she'd actually
ever met him after he became darth vader later
through some time travel nonsense in the world
between worlds ezra bridger saves her and she
winds up traveling in time to a few months later
during the events of the original trilogy and then
goes on jedi walk about communing with the force
and helping locals as she bounces around the outer
rim territories again there's really no official
canon story for exactly what she was doing day to
day or specific adventures during the events of
the original trilogy but i think we'll learn a
little more about that from live action ahsoka on
the mandalorian series and wherever else she winds
up showing up in the disney plus series then right
after return of the jedi she shows up on star wars
rebels in this post-credits scene to take sabine
into the unknown regions to find ezra bridger
then a couple years later comes back to the outer
rim territories and starts working with bogotan
again as she said during episode 3. my assumption
in terms of the future of her character on the
mandalorian series is that she'll keep coming
back every season to help out until they have
their final battle with moff gideon in the new
empire whatever the new battle of mandalore winds
up being in the final season i talked about this
during my Bo Katan video last week but this is the
real end game of the show make all the marvel
avengers references you want we're in the end
game now they finally take the planet back from
moff gideon and get rid of him permanently and
because ahsoka had a cameo scene during the rise
of skywalker and that voices of the jedi scene
dave filoni explained that she was not dead
when that was happening so there is a really
old version of ahsoka somewhere 30 years in the
future she'd be in her 70s during this period
so that just implies that ahsoka will not die
during the events of the mandalorian series
just keep that in mind regardless of what kind of
twists they try to throw at us during the episodes
but post all your ahsoka mandalorian predictions
on the video my full mandalorian season 2 episode
5 video will post on friday it was directed and
written by dave filoni that's why everyone's
saying it's the ahsoka episode pretty safe bet i
will do a few more mandalorian bonus videos this
week so leave all your requests in the comments
below but everyone click here for my new baby
yoda dark troopers video to explain the ending of
episode 4 and click here for my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 4 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!